This is a busy shipping
lane and at any moment
something could go
wrong.
It only takes one
incident to literally
send this ordinance two
miles up into the air.
It has the potential to
be one of the largest
non-nuclear explosions
in the history of
mankind.
London and satellite
towns like Sheerness on
the coast face a deadly
threat.
The population could have
a casualty rate far
higher than anything it
suffered in the Second
World War.
Yet a one and a half kill
a ton blast isn't the
only thing that could
devastate London.
Worst case scenario, this
ordinance blows and
causes a tsunami.
Some analysts have
concluded it would race
up the Thames and smash
into the centre of
London.